Google Cloud just released generative AI
support in vertex AI as well as
something called generative AI app
builder or gen app builder for short so
what's a gen app anyway a gen app is an
app that incorporates generative AI
either by using AI to help create the
code or the design of the app itself or
it's an app that uses generated AI to
interact with its users or both
gen apps are popping up everywhere Bots
chat apps digital assistants custom
search engines you might have an idea
for a gen app yourself so need access to
generative AI models that are
transparent in factual basically you
want to know that they're not making
stuff up and that you'll be able to
trace the answers back to the source the
Gen apps you build with Gen adbuilder
will be based on Foundation models
trained by Google Cloud that means
they've respected Google's AI principles
like accountability bias avoidance and
safety testing
trusted testers are accessing gen app
builder now for Early Access
opportunities check out our Technical
Community Google Cloud innovators I
can't wait to build with you there